how's your day going she was flying so
yeah I love trains there's no trains
yeah so I'm saying jack not like here
though not like the infrastructure
there's one there's one train ready go
hey everybody it's gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode three night 393 19 of
the askgaryvee show and I'm super
excited we're on a on an athletic kick
here on the askgaryvee show great show
yesterday and and today I have the great
pleasure of introducing two incredible
women who I've been able to follow
because obviously they've done some work
through a client here at vaynermedia so
I've been able to watch from afar and
watch some of the content and I'm really
excited to introduce them and I'm really
excited they're here and they took a
train this morning which there's only
one train track in North Dakota and
we'll go into all that but why don't you
introduce yourselves to the vaynernation
I'm Jocelyn I'm Jocelyn and I'm Monique
Glamour twins we play hockey for the
u.s. women's team but we're currently on
maternity leave so we're going to camp
in a few weeks trying to get back on the
national team so and so like right to
the origin story how do how do these
twins from and where were you were born
in North Dakota how do these twins from
North Dakota get to a place where they
get to represent our country at the
highest levels in their sport well we
grew up our sorry dad played Division
one hockey at the University of North
Dakota we have four older brothers that
all played hockey and then we just kind
of followed them around when we were
younger and you were two youngest yes
there were 30 and
well there's one more birthday this
summer right now it's 30 31 32 33 34 all
right your parents were busy yes they're
crazy yes totally irresponsible yes so
you just follow them around playing
whatever sports they were playing but
hockey is the big thing we have long
winters there and of course literally
play outside on the frozen pond by our
parents house and we grew up being able
to compete at a high level went to a
boarding school in Minneapolis right
outside Minneapolis and at the earliest
levels you were you were playing
obviously mixed with boys and things
that nature with all boys we actually
didn't have a girls team to play on and
because yeah there's no girls playing so
we played with boys until high school
yep I need one or two great stories on
this cuz I decide boys are idiots and
probably yeah I'm probably grossly
underestimated you some sure there's
gotta be like I need one like classic
story that you guys love to tell our dad
always told so we played three years of
checking and so our when we started
checking we were probably like middle of
pack size wise before all the boys
started hitting puberty and our dad
always told us and practice or in a game
he would say find that the biggest kid
on the other team and you put him on
their ass like that that's what he would
tell us so and you listened blindly yeah
oh yeah
I specifically remember it was our
peewee year and I was I played defense
and so I had knocked a kid over pretty
good and our coach came back he goes hey
don't hate him so hard next time and
then he liked what he liked started
walking away and he goes he goes don't
listen to me he goes you do you keep
doing that interesting you remember it
was Brandon Lunik interesting that yeah
I mean as they get older and start to
realize like okay it's not cool to have
girls on your team or yeah the dynamic
changed a little bit dynamic oh yeah it
changed quite a bit and so some of the
things guys I mean I'm very not
appropriate for yes especially in
today's environment some of the things
that go the girls are the best players
on your team while our team's beating
yours so I see so got it there was from
the opposing team you kind of like talk
about that yeah so I mean
not yet I mean just not the smartest and
how didn't you guys think about it you
know obviously thinking about your age
at that point where were we educating me
here a little bit where were we with
Olympic female hockey so the first
Olympics for women's hockey was 98 9 so
that was so how old we're in first grade
what are you like [ __ ] pumped did
that hit your radar were you like wait a
minute
yeah yeah right a bunch of sports
growing up and our mom was a huge
Olympics fan so she out whenever the
Olympics run we were watching not just
hockey we were just watching was your
mom one of those people that loved the
back story and like yeah yeah Costas
would get her so into like the farm girl
and like now her whole life predicator
8:18 p.m. to watch the rings to make
sure that little farm girl one classic
Olympic marketing yeah it just loves it
also we we just whatever sport we were
playing at the time so we play a ton of
sports growing up it was we're gonna go
what was your favorite sport growing up
actually on that note like what you
liked the most not necessarily what you
were best at
aside from hockey oats a soccer and but
hockey was number one it was such a
religion and your family was that what
it was if it wasn't the wintertime
though we love like soccer I mean pure
joy like out of like like you actually
and you're like you know call it six to
twelve years old like if the world said
you can only play one thing not where
your opportunities are like what you
enjoy the most was it hockey what was it
I would say was hockey in soccer yeah
hockey and soccer why I don't know how
it is New York but North Dakota you can
play it's definitely very different than
North Dakota York I promise you like I
don't know where you're going but it's
different play it just go they can play
like high school varsity sports as a 7th
and 8th grader so we played varsity
soccer and Ron ran cross-country on
varsity as 7th and 8th graders and so we
were as like 12 14 year olds were
playing with juniors and seniors in high
school it's in soccer school loved it
and it was we did really well so I would
say soccer if it wasn't a key for sure
and so let's keep going through the
progression you go to boarding school
yep where'd you guys go together yes was
there ever a consideration to not be
together so you guys go through that
because we left home at that age our how
old we would have been 15 they only went
that early because we were together made
them feel comfortable yeah I was
definitely I think a comfort thing for
our parents but we shouldn't
it's a Shattuck st. Mary's which is a
pretty prestigious vibe kind of like
port looks probably Sydney Crosby and
Nathan MacKinnon Zach Parise you could
name like teen [ __ ] all guys yep and
like us too and then Brianna Decker
Amanda Kessel we're all on the last two
Olympic teams three of her us but
they've reduced the number of pretty
good so huge program yes women's team
yes and were you guys good I mean I know
you guys were good to the t1 yeah we
want three out of four national
championships the four years were there
say that's good so let's really focus
and then the worst yeah being serious I
love losing like it drives the [ __ ] out
of me so I'm actually very curious what
year did so these were your four high
school years in theory so which year did
is our senior year [ __ ] yeah
no you will completely conviction like
wow we're gonna win it all yeah I shot
the team 42 to 11 in the party stones on
her head yeah it was probably the best
game she's ever played in her and do you
hate her deeply I don't know who she is
but so we in the quarterfinals yeah was
like the whole place stunned is that
your most devastating loss Oh gold medal
game Olympics still kills you so mad
about that one
so background around that we were up to
- nothing with about three minutes left
in the game
I remember these highlights came back
real hard yeah they came back tied it up
with like a minute left we go into
overtime
losing overtime so that was even though
like we want how often Williams how
often will you think about that game
like in real life
like does it come like do you think
about it like once a year once a day
once a month I mean I think well now
that were parents
not as I would say you're able to think
about it last yeah yeah fair enough
because you're busy they're not its
perspective but but do you think about
when we think about our hockey career
there's always well that of course yeah
like you say you hate losing and it's
you hate losing but I'm talking we're
like back to parent life right like
you're driving to the supermarket and
for some reason you think about like
[ __ ] if I just what if I just bat
checked that like I just think about
like I think about this [ __ ] and pick up
basketball that nobody on earth remember
is some like man real [ __ ] greats
that their split you know for everybody
who's listening there's any context for
hockey that that's an unusual thing to
happen in a hockey match especially a
bat magnitude you know and you start
thinking about like what's like I don't
know I just think about like do you
think about like oh [ __ ] like you know
did I hit the post in the second period
and it would've been three nothing like
I don't know the nuances of the game of
that specific game but like I just
wonder you know especially the way you
framed it up like when you grew up in a
family that is framed up the way you
guys just springed it up I don't think
people on you know I you know it's funny
I associate with athletes a lot because
of entrepreneurship yeah like
entrepreneurship was so like I'm a very
unique entrepreneur and the fact that
entrepreneurship what you know you know
it's funny I actually associate with
things like women's hockey quite a bit
let me explain in the 80s and 90s
entrepreneurship was not a thing this
was the thing it was called school and
you had to go to a good car car will
report card so in the 80 you know right
now I'm living a very interesting life
where entrepreneurship is cool and
everybody wants to be one but like when
I was really doing it and sacrificing I
mean that's not a bad report card you
know like like when I was doing that I
was a purebred entrepreneur as similar
as I could get to somebody who would go
away to boarding school to be there for
hockey and obviously have to keep up
your grades to be on the team all that
stuff but like you know but it was
underrated like people thought I was a
loser even though I was you know making
all this money selling big sports cards
on the weekend but because I got these
in F's my friend's parents thought I
would never amount to anything it was
that much of the religion anyway just
knowing how I grew up were everything
and it wasn't less about my parents cuz
they were
my dad was just working all the time but
it was more like for me it was just like
there was nothing it was just like it
was always in the air like back to that
like I'm imagining pictures in my head
of like you guys eating peas and like
trying to score on each other with your
brothers at like with the fort like it's
just in the DNA yeah I mean when you
think of elite athletes and people that
are at the tip of the spear or whatever
they're doing I mean you think it you
look at you sports today and kids
everyone's like oh I'm gonna go to they
specialize early they put their kids in
all these things but then when you look
at like the tip of the Spirit like who's
been successful they're willing to do
what no one else is doing wrecked when
they get when they get older when it's
appropriate to be specializing correct
and everyone everyone thinks they want
to do it but then when you get down to
like the day-to-day of what it takes to
get to sacrifice everything social you
aren't actually and you're wanting to do
that I couldn't react that when you look
at I mean even when you get to the top
of the top there's still people not
willing to do that yeah I mean at the
top at the top
I'm sure again you guys have better
framework than I do but like I'm so
passionate about it I look at it very
carefully
we also my brother and I also have an
NFL sports representation business where
25 guys you know I'm sure you saw this I
don't know how you guys equate for
yourselves how hard you worked or what
sacrifices you made but at the top of
the top when you see that passiveness
you have to marvel at the extreme talent
right like like I'm right like you know
I'm sure you've seen people who've just
not put in the work that have made the
Olympic team or your competitors and
you're like [ __ ] she is just so [ __ ]
talented now they a lot of those players
tend to leave so much on the table and
they could have been a top 10 player
all-time versus a non all-star yeah
that's where the variable comes in and
they had it being like a one-time
Olympian correct correct but I think
probably from your perspective you still
marvel at the sheer talent to even get
to the top of the top yeah I mean
without we're in New York was it two
years ago for that it was the year out
event for Pyeongchang and we went to our
first NBA game
it was actually was game that Charles
Oakley yeah but we were you know a
couple couple cents off of a couple
rolls off the floor and I mean we're we
enjoy sports but not huge NBA fans but
maybe this speed speed and you just
don't appreciate it on TV but when
you're on them you're like on the floor
like 30 feet away from it it's actually
a favorite thing about hockey
when when I've taken people from other
countries to a game or when I was a kid
just the amount of times that I've
serendipitously through business been at
a hockey game where somebody rarely
watches hockey has also skated for for
like at the rink for Christmas and like
within the first five seconds just
completely gets flabbergasted at the
skill level of the skating needed it's
similar to the speed it takes for
somebody to actually be in the NBA yeah
I mean it's it's impressive and those
there's no big the little space that
they have to work in with its we were
impressed what are you guys about now
like what is what is your passion right
now you know obviously we have you know
in in two years this video be watched
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of thousands of times what are
you guys passionate about what are you
trying to put into the world so we just
actually launched our foundation last
night okay it was a layup question yeah
it's a we're really excited so we just
what's it called wood snuck in Joss and
Landrieu foundation and we've been very
fortunate to travel the country with
Comcast as ambassadors for the corporate
values initiatives and so we're using
our platform as Olympic athletes to give
back and that's been amazing to do on a
national level and to travel but now we
basically ask ourselves what can we what
can we do on a day to day like what what
are we really doing in our own community
and so we felt like launching a
foundation was the way to do that so
we're gonna give backward our first
initiative is we're going to announce
soon but probably will be with the
school lunch program
yeah and our kind of our credo is cheer
for the one behind so our mom when we
were younger of all the different sports
we do if it was ever something that we
were competing against each other
swimming or cross-country or whatever it
was it was I'm gonna cheer for the one
that's behind because she didn't want to
have to like pick one over the other and
so first of all I'm already all about
your mom because I'm also by default
more underdog nature yeah I've watched a
lot I actually was it's funny you guys
went there I was about to ask you a
question about this and it's been funny
I noticed the same reason everybody in
New York is wearing Steph Curry jerseys
because people are bandwagon fans
because they don't have their own self
esteem and I've watched a lot of parents
actually cheer for the kid that's better
and I've always been fascinated by that
because I love this chipper - one like
that would absolutely be the way for me
so I'm a huge fan of your mom she's
great she makes a good latte - yes
really is that like a thing where you
know about Linda's lattes Indo India why
don't we open one in Portland me you and
and the mom tima three-headed monster
I'm telling you I know how to mark an
help okay yeah so we that's kind of
something that it for us it kind of
transcended sports and just into other
parts of our lives I remember in like at
the time I didn't like think anything
I've been sixth grade and there was a
kid that sat next to me we sat
alphabetical order he had Down syndrome
his name was Justin and he would sit by
himself and lunch I was like hey just
like why don't you come sit with us like
so it was that table of girl sent girls
you'd come and sit with us and be like
kind of became like the cool kids so
that was in the sixth grade by eighth
grade he was just like migrate from
table to table love you and then like
unbeknownst to us he I think his mom I
think his mom or ground like sends a
letter to the school and then they sent
it to our parents are like I didn't tell
my parents photos it's like yeah be nice
and so then actually we were doing an
event like a couple months ago and his
grandma can't come to the
and then we're doing like a quick
meet-and-greet afterwards and she was
like I'm like I'm Justin's Graham I'm
like oh my god so I was just like little
things like that where we're just trying
to be nice and are you a good person and
kindness is so underrated yes I can yes
I push it so heavily I'm fascinated by
people not understanding how life
actually works well it just doesn't make
sense no Brian go through life like that
and be in well why because unlike the
three of us we were fortunate enough to
have a situation where we weren't
hurting inside and manifesting like when
I watch people not be kind I deploy
empathy and sadness for that person
because I'm like what's really going on
back home is super not interesting
mm-hmm
that's the manifestation of a bad
environment or bad parenting or a
terrible circumstance mm-hmm you know
and so nonetheless what is the biggest
fight you two ever got into go against
each other against each other's each
other well you know what I I had braces
and I also had to wear headgear when I
was at home I didn't have to wear it in
public at least and why'd you have to
wear oh the headgear for the braces yeah
under shake it like some old 19 we just
call you this yeah you guys were so
unstoppable I always think about the
reason I'm unstoppable emotionally is
all the bad stuff happened so early like
you know didn't speak English I was an
immigrant got picked on terrible in
school everybody thinks I'm a loser
wasn't athletically inclined enough that
very quickly my hand-eye coordination
skills went away by third grade and I'm
losing
and so it's like loss loss loss loss
loss that by the time I became a grown
up I'm like [ __ ] all of you and just
thinking about having the luxury of
having four alpha athletic brothers be
older than you I'm like wow these ladies
fundamentally unstop see on us like
everything was a competition like
getting to the front seat of the car was
a competition so like the key though was
to not be first cuz you were just gonna
get blown
been out of the way checking where we if
we ever wanted to take long and play
with them it was well if you can't keep
up then you can't play with us so that
was like what we that was just our
normal growing up which brother are you
closest to oh I would say is different
for a different reason of course and he
not two of them still play overseas it's
awesome where one one's going to Germany
now and the other our oldest Phil is he
using Austria and the youngest one is
going to Germany now understand Austria
so of the four of them who thinks what's
the debate of like who's that of the six
kids
what is the macro debate Nate net-net
don't give me the politically correct
like oh she's the best at skating and he
was the best of puck skate like who's
considered of the six in the family
dynamics like your own little text chain
or dinner table like it inevitably there
has to be a debate of like net net like
rankings well there's always a goalie so
he doesn't care out and then how does he
feel about that
he was why was he wholly like this yeah
and was he the oldest yes makes like if
we would play street hockey
so I our games would inevitably answer
like either Phil would break all the
glow sticks cuz he'd like break them
over the net because you've been always
super low-key and like laid-back total
spaz see I associated with that I'm
pretty in the schema don't confuse my
energy with like me being pretty chill
in the way I do things in real life but
in sports
I'm completely unhinged like to the
point where right now I actually don't
want to do sports anymore really because
where I've evolved into is actually
genuine this is so dark I genuinely want
to injure people that is like think
about like how uncomfortable that was to
come out of my mouth like that is so
remarkably inappropriate and like yeah
and my genuine truth well so then our
brother Joe that's a jock would always
like kind of cross the line a little bit
with like slashing someone so he would
have hurt somebody
someone like this family and then
pierre-paul I might be the seventh child
always good to like throw an elbow at
someone and like get mad and then Mario
would just root for the North Stars not
really well they were gone yeah go ahead
we're just fans really he's gonna have a
family team yeah and all like I heard
really no nobody not dad down
nobody had a team all Phil I guess Phil
like the leaves but we're just back to
our dad he would like when we're playing
checking you if someone like got the
best of us or like knocked us over he
goes you don't get back you get even so
I kept there yeah you get them back
better yeah or just say if you're gonna
take if you're gonna take a penalty goes
make it worth it type of thing so
growing up they maybe they can call it
when we like in high school college and
a little bell and a national team like
that we would get ourselves a little bit
of trouble sometimes cuz we were just
like I'm gonna beat the [ __ ] out of
somebody let me show you I'll show ya ya
type thing and then my dad's like why
did you do that like and then you think
I was like for so many years telling you
all these who's the who's the best
player that you played against just for
your own person you know just your own
personal each of you I'm just curious
like what gal like and it could be at
any level like when you got the boarding
school or an Olympic game or like a
singular game like obviously that one
goalie that stood on her head yeah but
like like but in a net-net I'm just
actually just genui fastening I'm on
Team Canada Megan Augusta I think a year
in and year out has been one of their
best players and kinda has been a little
under the radar in my opinion or under I
would say underappreciated a little
could you see the subtle thing she does
yeah like she's just consistently on the
scores on the score sheet all the time
and so it's I think one of our coaches
last year had asked like okay what who
are we who are we watching for on their
team and I was like number two like
thinking like how do you obviously like
captain pool and she scored two goals in
Vancouver we lost - nothing she scored
two goals when we're in Sochi when we
lost three - so of course everyone's
paying attention her she's pretty good
yeah she's doing pretty good which team
which team globally is emerging from
Finland Finland
yes last year at the World Championships
every World Championships has been a US
Canada final except this year was a us
Finland final which went to a shootout
so Finland's quickly imagined pretty
good and then the last like year and a
half or so they've really stepped up and
it's like everyone just assumes it's a
US Canada final and we're are we on the
landscape of a professional women's
league globally we're working on it
right now so I don't know how familiar
you are with what's what's transpired
I'm not but but Budweiser is our client
at vaynermedia and we had a very
interesting campaign that we just
launched post you might have saw it just
seems a subtle way to put it I mean we
think it's amazing thank you so we're
really excited about it we we recognized
what I'm sure you know very extreme in
soccer and definitely to a lesser degree
but clearly in culture from my
standpoint happens to the Olympic hockey
women's hockey team which is and then
the next yay
or like devastation and then the next
day we'll see you in four years yeah I
just we have we worked when we when we
had the hypothesis when I saw the team
working on it and they came up with a
great idea to support it post the World
Cup I start I did my own googling
because I I mean this is I'm pretty in
tune with like a lot of things let alone
sports and did not know that are perfect
like the that even the league existed
right that's just done on it that's full
transparency and then when I looked into
it looking at those attendance numbers
yeah and then just think about the start
you know I look
these wrestling figures are here for a
reason I actually believe that any sport
can capture America's attention if you
know how to build superstars yeah so
like 19 you know a lot of what it's been
interesting about watching you with God
Comcast that's how I think right Tony
Hawk right Kelly Slater the you know the
1982 NBA Finals was on tape delay in
America the 1982 NBA the 1982 NBA Finals
was not live in America because there
was that little interest in the NBA and
then David Stern with obviously you need
Larry Bird and Magic Johnson and Michael
Jordan to be who they are but guess what
you know the Iceman George Gervin and
Connie Hawkins and dr. J were pretty
remind Pistol Pete were pretty
remarkable they weren't in a framework
that understood how to build but it's
what's happening at baseball
baseball I mean baseball is America is
becoming more Hispanic Latin every day
yeah the greatest athletes in American
sport that are Hispanic are in Major
League Baseball yeah and yet they don't
know how to use Vladimir Guerrero or
Fernando to teach junior or Javier Baez
so I'm always fascinated I genuinely
believe America like is is a is a Fame
star culture and when you have Mike
Tyson and America cares
boxing's huge and when you don't they
don't and so I you know I genuinely
believe that um that women's athletics
across the board are really fascinating
at the professional level because I
think of it as star power for the WNBA
this women's soccer league whatever
you're about to tell me about the hockey
league like that to me is like how do we
do what Vince McMahon does which is he
makes us care about Hulk Hogan and Randy
the Macho Man Savage and Andre the Giant
and they're not even actually that's a
that's a soap opera John Michaels the
Heartbreak Kid right that's a soap opera
and when you and it's a framework and so
when you have Hulk Hogan and macho man
and Andre you have an era and then you
go cold for a while and then when you're
lucky enough to get the charisma of
Stone Cold Steve Austin and the rock you
have that era right the Undertaker that
to me is fascinating about sports in
America well if you think of like hockey
not just women's hockey but I think
hockey's kind of the last professional
sport where it's it everyone it's it's a
team don't bring any attention to
yourself don't have like any personality
and I feel like hockey is kind of like
the last sport that's finally kind of
being accepting of that because for salt
I mean you look at PK Subban and the
amount of negative attention people like
he gets for well he's off on his own
he's doing as well like people are
allowed to have personality NHL was one
of eater media's first clients in 2009
and I remember Brendan Shanahan had me
come and speak to all the kids that were
about to get drafted and I was spitting
all this thoughts about what social
media can do and all the stuff that is
now accepted and to your point and it's
the same thing in baseball and it's the
same thing for rookies in any sport Yeah
right there's more you know us normal
people don't understand the judgment
pressures inside of a locker room that
go do anything that isn't on team and
the NBA is the one place where that is
embraced and that is the biggest reason
it is exploded in the direction it has
because there is individualism that is
accepted while being able to in parallel
and move 100% yeah on top of having
individualism and not it being judged
but then being able to promote it within
the team like anybody and letting merit
play out right like individualism in
basketball is really fascinating
Tim Duncan just announced yesterday he's
gonna be an assistant coach the level of
superstar to go to assistant coach not
head coach hasn't been done at the level
of Tim Duncan but that's his DNA he was
always a quiet superstar yeah right like
and yeah I mean anyway nonetheless
please tell me about it cuz I'm actually
very fascinated what is the current
state so there used to be two leagues in
North America so there's a Canadian
league
an American League and we already call
what were they see WHL the Canadian
Women's Hockey League so that they
folded understood yes spring so they
just fold it and then the NW HL the
National Women's Hockey League still
exists there's a team in Minnesota and
then it's three teams on the East Coast
Buffalo New York and Canada in
Connecticut awesome or fourteens Boston
Connecticut New York there is a New York
team and Buffalo so it's four teams on
the East Coast yeah and so there's five
teams in the league
there's five teams and so that league we
feel as some of the top players in the
world we feel like that's it's not a
sustainable league you have to have
proof of insurance
other insurance to be able to play and
were you guys in that league now have
you opted to not play in that league
understood when did that league start
four years ago I see so it started at a
time where you're in a different place
in your career as well yes yeah and I
mean it's just not we're both married
I'm not we're not moving to a different
city to go play I guess I guess mm that
was to my point I mean it would have
been an interesting conversation
potentially at 22 yeah it would have
been interesting how you have debated it
its values and its merits but understood
but anyway so right now currently
anyone's making its between like four
and twelve thousand dollars for the
season I understand the attendance
numbers must be really uncomfortably low
yes I don't know them off the
competition so it has these numbers but
then decent as in less than 2000 yes
around that would make sense to me you
know enough about minor league hockey
and things of that nature
yeah okay so we have opted there's we've
created a Players Association it's an
official Players Association it's
incorporated all that and the top 100
it's 170 players or in the Association
but it's like the top players in the
world or a part of it and you can't go
back right we're sitting you're gonna go
backwards and find the right humans to
start a league with as partnership yes
yep so we're operated as sustainable I'm
such an entrepreneur I'm like I'm
hysterical right now
I'm like so one-dimensional everything's
yes okay so that's [ __ ] for currently
the three mission of the PA is to create
playing opportunities next season while
players sit out of the current
professional situation in North America
so that's in short what's going on good
for you that's really neat I may want to
talk to you about that off podcast all
right I mean it
thank you super interesting uh as we're
wrapping up I want to give you a few
minutes to talk about things that you
wanted to talk about in here versus me
nerding out on the nuances of your guys
professional hockey career well I think
as Midwest John went to I apologize
go ahead as Monique touched on we've
done the cheer for the one behind that's
like that's our mission that's that's
what we're all about and challenging
people to do that whether that's in a
small capacity on you know a day-to-day
thing or it's on a larger capacity like
we've created a foundation to try and
truly make a tangible difference
something that we can see but it's also
being able to raise awareness around
issues and not being afraid to speak
about things you guys be picking those
issues well it's already combination
yeah yes you know kept it vague where we
basically can we want to be able to pick
and choose what we want to get
passionate one of the things my stocking
boughs like the free or the school lunch
program so if we're looking at how we're
gonna might be able to fund that in our
in our hometown because there's some of
the schools are like it's like over 80
percent qualify for free and they're
free and reduced lunch and so if we can
give back to those products so that a
fundamental level like kids are expected
to go to school and learn if you're
hungry it's pretty hard to learn yes it
is so I Know Who I am when I get hangry
so I imagine cancer you have to go just
at a fundamental level if we can get
kids just starting at the same point as
everybody else and at an education
standpoint and I think that's something
we're great already I want to do a quick
speed round when we get this first call
in first and last uh what are you binge
watching
you know I look at the things I did that
one I'm still with the six month all
they don't binge watch any room I get it
but I'm like two episodes and the
stranger things my spell to better
ensure noble is a good one oh my god
everybody giving me up about that and
since I got lucky enough and left that
area right before it happened
oh very uh one more second I apologize
what about your favorite social media
platform like Instagram I think
different ones for different reasons so
I feel like Facebook is more like friend
friends yeah you actually do show
Instagram more visual day-to-day and
then Twitter want to catch up on the
news or like okay well you play with all
three yeah cool um yeah we lost it
so I'll get one more bench question
while you type uh who was your favorite
athlete growing up nope no politically
correct answers so she would have been
she would have been we were too young to
remember her compete remember we
actually Comcast event that's awesome
yeah last year we're just like you
couldn't wait to Vic you couldn't wait
to take that picture and son to your mom
yes yes we actually brought her on her
trip with us so Jackie joyner-kersee for
you I was gonna say I love gymnastics
okay thanks so like the was the
Magnificent Seven
yeah I mean we still nerd out over the
Olympics like Helen such an athlete
Helen yeah you're on the askgaryvee show
how are you and she hung up let's call
her no I want to call Helen this is a
moment call her right back
she's that good no I think she was
stunned oh oh you think she said no when
we dialed the number wrong or it's got
it looks ready got this is really good
this is 701 number no.6 one for this is
exciting now come on hello Helen
no they did not have one oh I'm sorry I
will not call you again sorry Andi right
Ryan it's Ryan holy crap are you serious
we are not joking Ryan say hello please
what's up Ryan hey it's Ryan
hey how's it going hey so I have twin
girls three year old girls alright it's
a good start and and I am trying my best
to instill confidence in them at an
early age allowing them to be as
individuals but also at the same time
building the your uniqueness as twins as
well and so my question is also to you
guys and also the Gary to you you don't
you have a daughter and my question is
is how do I build that confidence in
them as individuals but also at the same
time allow their uniqueness to flow as
twins as well well I'll take the
confidence piece of it and I don't think
as a as three-year-olds I think you do
what you can is the best you can as a
parent to teach them right from wrong
and you let them struggle within a
certain capacity so they learn to be
independent and learn how to do things
on their own but so yeah problem solved
but confidence as you get all it's not
something someone can give you and it's
not something someone can take away from
you and I think that that's how you
build security and confidence and you
it's it's not something that should
change day to day obviously your
confidence can go up and down with
everything going on in life but I think
I mean that's that's a tough thing that
I'd all struggle with every day but yeah
right I think of when we were younger
our dad always like we would call it the
face in the mirror speech so whether
whatever it was that we were doing or
whether it was a game school whatever
activity we were in it was always if you
can if you can look yourself in the in
the mirror and say you did the best you
can or you put your best foot forward
and you worked your hardest then even
though the outcome might not be what you
wanted it to be you can be satisfied
with your effort and you can't be
disappointed in yourself and I think by
having that mindset I think that helps
create confidence as far as the twin
question goes our parents always put
everything in us together and we just
always did everything together and our
mom always said two is better than one
so we were always used like in that
aspect that we have the same group of
friends we had all this did all the same
sports and whatnot and some twins don't
get along like that or spend a lot of
time together so I think I think we're
sledding yeah I think just letting that
develop over time because they might end
up having all the same interest they
might not and that just as they get
older and how their personalities
develop I think that you'll kind of find
your way with that awesome I thank you
very much I think yeah yeah just add my
two cents because I'm super passionate
about obviously I really can't speak
with any authority on the twin level but
but but there are two things that stand
out to me number one I do think reverse
engineering individuals at scale is
something I'm very passionate about
having all these different employees and
there's so many different dynamics and I
think it is a fine line between the two
is better than one which I think the
optimism that that breeds I think is
incredible and I think is oh it's always
better to lean into optimism versus
pessimism and cynicism but where I'm
about to go with the rest of that
sentence is actually the answer to
confidence I think the number one
vulnerability in society is delusion I
think that parents are creating a
remarkable level of delusion over the
last 20 years because parents have
become so my
managing of their kids feelings and
actually know their day to days too much
which n are trying to protect them from
the world which unfortunately is
fundamentally impossible and I believe
that we have one to two full generations
right now that are closer to zoo animals
than they are humans and so as I was
listening to the stories as we were
talking here I think one of the great
things that is true about the three of
us upbringing was we were in frameworks
because of circumstances
we're losing wasn't demonized or
protected against it was the merit of
the outcome which got us comfortable
with the idea of which meant by the time
we were actually 22 we actually knew
that that was part of the variable and
it is remarkably stunning to me to watch
the enormity of 22 year olds that go
into the world who demonize and fear
losing or setbacks because they've been
in a / coddled fake framework
environment where grades have been the
only variable or seventh place trophies
feel close to a first-place trophy or or
or mommy and daddy pay for uber or the
apartment and we are just in a very
entitled ecosystem I think the biggest
thing you can do for those
three-year-olds to create self-esteem
and confidence is to make them be in an
environment where losing is reality and
almost even put on a pedestal without it
being something that they dwell on post
the outcome in a real way yeah not in a
fake way like the amount of parents that
I'm watching like Gary here I'm you know
they hear me talking about this that
will give me the full 15 sentence you
know email and it's like I let my kids
lose and it's some convoluted fake loss
yeah like it's like they lost in color
Wars this summer I'm like bro that's
like I'm like cool but like it's like we
like really get in underneath this and
this gets into athletics is fascinating
the amount of parents that are so
delusional thinking their kids going to
the league
yeah I mean this is why you're reacting
like this as an actual professional
athlete like like not like breaking news
everybody listening and watching right
now your kids not going to the league
whatever league that is because the math
is uncomfortably against you and so the
amount of parents that are wrapping
their self-esteem into their kids
outcomes in school and in sports this is
one huge game of mass insecurity at the
parent level you want those two girls to
be happy never let your mom siblings
teachers or best friends points of view
on your children ever penetrate your
mind that's awesome yeah and that's
that's one thing that really tried my
hardest that even with them you know
just the basics of falling I instantly
say to them hey that was a fantastic
fall like you know you fell yeah you got
a straight you got a boo-boo you know
that thought but let's you know let's
continue forward and let's let's
continue and and and you need to find
the balance between probably what these
two amazing gals grew up with which was
there was no fantastic fall words out of
their dad's mouth there was get the [ __ ]
up out of there Matt yeah so I I don't
think this is worth and by the way let
me just say this as I keep on this rant
giving parenting advice is the least
interesting thing on earth everybody
like like it's just not interesting but
it's like a fun macro debate not a micro
debate so before I go any further you do
you however my point of view in the
macro is all of us have to decide what a
fantastic booboo is versus a boo-boos
are real like here's a band-aid let's go
and everything in between like I think
we're in a culture right now where
fantastic booboo and like is like very
much more common and it's politically
incorrect to do what their dad did or
what I believe in of like get the [ __ ]
up and like and you got to know your kid
and some kids respond incredibly well to
get the [ __ ] up some don't you got to
stay in listening mode but this is just
real life this is just real life like I
think my mom is the greatest mother of
all time
I'm the byproduct of it and the one time
my mom tried to enter a conversation of
how I should parent it was a three
second conversation of shut the [ __ ] up
mom and I and I realized when I did that
to somebody who I think is my hero is
the best mom on earth I was excited
because I was like wow I really believed
in the [ __ ] that I talk about I am NOT
gonna let anybody penetrate my mindset
it's very cute that you fly in on the
weekends once in a while and have a
point of view you're not here 24 it's
the same reason that I even walk tread
lightly with my opinions to my wife
who's there actually every second versus
me flying in on the weekends if they
like it's like the one place I'm like
[ __ ] this sucks
like for me to stay and not be a
hypocrite I got to be thoughtful here
that's what I would say bro you kids and
everybody needs to feel safe but not
entitled and that [ __ ] fine line is
hard as [ __ ] but if you keep repeating
that sentence it allows you to have
multiple moves the biggest issue that
parents have now is they've one move I
think if you go fantastic booboo and get
the [ __ ] up and you mix them up you've
got a much better chance than one or the
other and that's the net the main reason
why I like going I'd like you for they
have to get going cuz being these kids
at the time and time again whether it'll
sit in one spot and just cry for 10
minutes about this one booboo where
there's plenty more opportunities to go
ahead and keep playing and and you know
move forward - I've already convinced my
six-year-old who lives for basketball
that he will never dunk and that took
and that took two months of being okay
with him I mean he's also his dad's son
like he cries 24/7 like I had so many am
like all my emotional intelligence now
is my greatest strength but from 6 to 15
I couldn't control feeling everything
and so I just [ __ ] cried every I want
every single thing I lost him from 1982
to 1989
I cried pool cried football cried tennis
cried cried cried for kids that got
picked on that's why I love you so much
cried for kids that got picked on it's a
kids getting picked on at lunch
and I'm over here crying for that person
like couldn't control them so my son's
got that thing too so telling him he's
not gonna dunk now is painful as [ __ ]
most parents don't want micro pain they
don't realize they're creating macro
pain um oh it hurts like hell watching
him cry for 20 minutes
full steam of like [ __ ] basically [ __ ]
you daddy why can't I dunk and the
interest genetics Pro like it's just not
gonna happen but but he also and this is
crazy for me to say I can't even believe
this happened
he almost actually beat me in pappad
shot basketball this weekend because his
jump shot is so insane cuz he stopped
dunking on his little [ __ ] thing
after I finally got through to him and
he's shooting from such range and I'm
like like and his euro-step and his left
hand and now he will be an unbelievably
good pickup basketball player one day
and that's awesome you know and so like
and so like to me that's like that's
something parents need to bring into the
framework versus what I see 90% doing
which is the reverse of what I just did
which is you'll dunk one day son you're
gonna dunk and then me paying because of
my ability like NBA coaches to teach him
when he's in eighth grade on one-on-one
and then somewhere around 15 he's like
I'm [ __ ] delusional well if you just
use sport like for us like Sports is
like it's a microcosm of life you
hundred percent use it to teach be a
good teammate rejection from others
listen to your coaches having a good
attitude working working hard
accountability all those things you want
to talk about one that like I know we're
so over and I got a run but like you
know what my favorite one is and I'm
sure you've done this you don't wait
favorite thing that people learn about
in sports that nobody ever says out loud
knowing when not to listen to a coach
I've never heard anybody say that and
when I watch like kids like or like just
watching I'm like like I literally watch
that way like I watch like I've hired
people here when they've been interns by
the way they've played Nate is my
partner in empathy whines because that's
an intern the way he played volleyball
made me know he would be good and it
played out like I'm being serious like
like knowing when to not listen to the
coach is such a subtle to be respect
harassing what's funny pretend like
you're listening no no you nailed it you
know what I think about this I was the
most disruptive force in my classrooms
from third grade to senior year in our
senior breakfast which was a really cool
tradition at our high school somebody
got up and said like my favorite thing
about high school was hoping I was in
gary vaynerchuk's class because I knew
that he would always waste 7 to 13
minutes the fact that the fact that I
was able to do that and still be liked
by my teachers like is now in hindsight
so much of what I am similar to what you
just said which is knowing when not to
listen to the coach but not being an
issue yep because players on the field
still know yep you know like and that
confidence like oh so anyway anyway
nonetheless thanks for the call ladies
thank you so much for being on the I
really appreciate uh this is really fun
is how we wrap up you get to ask the
question of the day any question you
want for the audience fire away we were
talking we kind of touched on a little
bit earlier but in women's professional
sports not doesn't any hockey yep what
do you think neat is like the tipping
point to bring it to the next level I
think you're some starting up seeing the
NWSL right now yeah but what do you as a
lot of professional entrepreneurs yes
what do you think well they're gonna
answer it
I think they're getting answer it you'll
get thousands of comments you'll see
that you're in your mom's basement
you're 40 just don't even bother
commenting and saying whatever you have
to say you mean you're going to cliche
the other way of like a disrespectful
comment yeah I mean honestly it's really
thank you for that question and I'll
leave it with this PS it's where I went
earlier I actually think under the radar
sports are far more interesting to me
I'm fun I'm far more interested in
things that aren't top five right now
because what they don't people to
understand that ninja matters for
eSports even though it's fortnight and
not necessarily even overwatch or League
or League of Legends like it's star
power that's what's gonna take it to the
next level it's Jackie joyner-kersee
it's long nails its Mary Lou Retton it's
these things
it's what the Olympics do they they take
America and
they do a mini-documentary it's what
24/7 was for boxing yeah right it got
people that had no interest seeing like
wait a minute
Manny Pacquiao's got a cute little kid
I'm really like its worry telling in
contemporary places the reason I got
excited about like oh maybe I should get
involved this league is I'm like okay
and then I'll do a deal with Facebook
and only air on Facebook because that's
where the new attention is and that's
just like cable which helped other
sports like it's about it's about
storytelling and attention but I'll let
them answer